est ce que vous pensez qu'il ya une
justice vous johan entre paris et
dunkerque par exemple pourquoi on la
voit la dunkerque vous est confiné et
nous on acquiert que les fallout france
à calais voilà tout ça ouais ouais l'eau
de fonte maintenant on comprend pas bon
parce que je veux dire chez nous aussi
bien le restaurateur fin tout le monde
tout le monde râle tout le monde de
tourner était prêt au vin certains
restaurateurs des amis qui étaient prêts
à ouvrir à être hors la loi parce qu'ils
en ont ras le bol et c'est
compréhensible
pourquoi paris on n'est pas confiné
alors que on est 500 cas pour 100000
habitants que chez nous on est à 300 350
kg par habitant
nous sommes six millions dans le pas de
calais fendra les autres france ouai
mais car dit il n'aurait pas de calais
vous êtes 12 millions en ile de france
donc vous êtes à peu près à 25000 quatre
couvées de et nous on est à 14 me un
atout comme ça donc je comprends pas
pourquoi le gouvernement on a un premier
ministre qui s'appelle albert dupontel
fait certainement par ailleurs si donc
lui je comprends pas pourquoi il confine
pas paris et que nous confirme nous pour
quoi faire me veut nous faire rentrer à
18 heures je prends l'exemple tout à
fait pareil pari est la différence à la
différence est qu'à 18h à paris j'ai
remarqué en arrivant des personnes de
rentrer à paris les personnes de rentrer
à rien tandis que chez nous en province
oui parce que les amendes je peux vous
dire j'ai pris deux périodes de senlis
ils étaient une trentaine de gendarmes
n'ont donc voilà sur le support accises
calme un peu là dessus parce qu'on n'est
pas non plus pour parler affaire il être
ensemble voilà s'activent aux sirènes
inquiète pas moyen donc pourquoi oui
pourquoi pourquoi nous et pourquoi 18h
pour cours laisse pas les gens au
minimum jusque 20h par exemple ils
sortent du boulot à 17h 17h30 18h
peut-être ils ont les gosses en garde à
la crèche maintenant de récupérer les
enfants faut faire une attestation à 18
heures pour récupérer enfin la cage et
vous avez plus de temps derrière pour
aller chercher votre peau du soir voilà
donc 20 heures ce sera très bien alors
au moins pousser deux heures de pied
alors juste laurent alexandre est ce que
la situation en ile-de-france permis
encore de ne pas faire de confinement le
week end ou de ne pas durcir les mesures
c'est très compliqué compte tenu du
waterloo vaccinale c'est à dire du
retard énorme qu'april europe 1 par
rapport aux pays développés dans la
vaccination la france daxing beaucoup
beaucoup plus lentement que le maroc au
chili
je parle même pas d'israël qui a fini le
programme de vaccination donc on est on
n'a pas encore d'immunité collective en
europe à part l'angleterre qui est qui a
vacciné extrêmement rapidement donc les
chiffres vous les connaissez ils sont
absolument apocalyptique ans ne
reviendra sur l'europe allemagne italie
s'est pas beaucoup mieux
non me l'europe l'euro il ne fait pas
mieux que la france a pris c'est
l'ensemble de l'europe qui a raté le
programme de vaccination par rapport à
israël qui des confidences inter qui va
bientôt des confiner les etats-unis qui
ont réouvert les restaurants on voit
qu'on est dans une phase où on difficile
donc le grave échec européen sur la
vaccination c'est qu'on n'a pas beaucoup
de choix
on va devoir re confiné au moins
partiellement en ile-de-france mais bien
sûr qu'on a été injuste et que compte
tenu du poids économique énorme de l'île
de france on a retardé au maximum leur
amplitude mende week-end en ile de
france alors qu'on a tapé sur les sur
les gens des hauts de france mais il
faut savoir que le confinement est
objectivement moins bien respectés à
paris ouais que dans les villes pauvres
du nord pas calais pour une raison
simple c'est que la haute bourgeoisie
parisienne et le soir fin kong et
l'amande voilà c'est ça ou avocat
d'affaires une une amende de 128 euros
vous en avez rien à [ __ ] quand vous
êtes joanne whalley revote mois